citizens of the reject Nation welcome to
my non-spoiler thoughts for Ant-Man
Quantum Mania which I did see in IMAX I
am now turning so you can actually see
me but that was very dramatic that
opening much like the movie very
dramatic I have a lot of very
conflicting feelings towards this movie
in that I really really want people to
enjoy it and I really want people to go
see it and I do think IMAX is the format
of choice there are so many scenes that
are shot for that scale ironically a
movie about an Ant-Man is very very big
and bold it is one of the most visually
stimulating movies I've seen in a very
long time but where my problems lie is
in the characterization because some of
these characters are being utilized in
new ways and a lot of these characters
are delivering a bigger Arc but my issue
much like I had with Age of Ultron is
that you're suffering in the temporary
Arc to have the overarching arc I feel
like this movie is going to grill on me
as I see where this goes but I
definitely feel like when I walked out
of the movie I didn't even know how to
begin to review it so let's go on this
journey together let's start with Kang
Kang is a Powerhouse Kang is Jonathan
Majors getting the flex majorly and I do
feel like what Jonathan Majors brings to
the table is an almost Shakespearean
meets
um Brando esque hyper masculinity that
is so for me a leaning in performance I
kept being fascinated by like little
choices and facial ticks and his eyes
and I was so captivated at all points by
Jonathan Majors my issue wasn't with his
performance as Kang it was some of the
writing choices for Kang and again this
is a non-spoiler review so I'm not going
to give anything away but I definitely
felt the reason Kang served this story
is going to be very different than how I
feel about Kang the character overall it
is not a spoiler to say tang in the
comic books Kang in reality Kang that
you already know you met him and he who
remains is a multi-faceted character so
the use of this Kang didn't work for me
all the time the delivery of this Kang
was always interesting but I don't know
if it actually worked for the story they
told hopefully that makes sense I'm very
excited to give a spoiler review because
all of this will be a very more linear
journey to tell you this as with any
Marvel movie does have two post-credit
scenes and the first one is a lot of
what I was really really wanting and I
really think it builds off of the last
five minutes really well the last five
minutes is actually a perfect example of
how I feel about this stuff okay so not
giving away the last five minutes but
the last five minutes was a lot more of
the thing I wanted the movie to lean
more into but because of the things the
movie had to be it wasn't allowed to be
the last five minutes so I love the last
five minutes and I loved the mid credit
scene but because this was the third in
an Ant-Man Trilogy because this was the
continuation of the 3637 Marvel film
Saga they couldn't do the thing that the
post-credits scene and the very end of
the movie was so I feel like this movie
was fighting itself as much as it was
fighting Kang I feel like this this
movie had a lot of really interesting
family Dynamics there's a couple little
tweets that would have elevated it from
you know like mid-level to upper level
that like literally it's it's a decision
here or a decision there but overall it
felt like it was warning with itself
because it was growing in a bunch of
directions at once but it definitely
felt like sometimes it played too small
and sometimes it played too big
sometimes it played two Ant-Man
sometimes it played two giant man most
of all I think it did a Star Trek Star
wars-esque film Justice and I I really
love that that's the flavor they
captured here this isn't like the heist
film the first one was this isn't the
adventure the second one was this is
truly a sci-fi film so whereas you've
got space operas with Guardians of the
Galaxy this is a more traditional sci-fi
film this has more DNA with elements of
of Loki than it does with elements of
Guardians of the Galaxy a lot of that
Mobius art and the character Mobius
makes that confusing but Mobius is a
comic artist that has a very intricate
design the final post-credits scene is a
really interesting choice in that it
reveals more than I think they've done
in a lot of them lately it also hearkens
back to phase one and two post-credit
scenes in in the style and the choice
and the use of the post-credits scene
and it also teases something that I
think the movie could have teased but
I'm glad they at least teased it it
didn't feel like uh you know Moon Knight
or one of the ones where it's like well
that could have just been the end of the
movie but it did definitely feel like I
would have liked more of that in the
movie highlights for me were definitely
Modoc uh I did not expect Modoc to be
the scene stealer he was uh you know
modox in this I did not spoil anything
he's in the trailer it was something
that I I had hoped would be the way they
made Modoc happen and they absolutely
nailed it I think it really fit with
World building I think it really fit
with balancing drama and comedy I think
it really fit with what they were
allowed to do with the science and
technology in this universe and I really
had so much fun with that choice and I
really enjoyed the family dynamic in
that I love that phase four really
addressed all of our heroes getting
older and really addressed what it'd be
like to be a superhero parent and I
really am enjoyed a lot of the Cassie
Lang Paul Rudd dynamic as well as
Evangeline Lily being a part of that and
then her relationship with her mom and
her relationship with Hank Pym and I do
think Hank Pym finally gets some of the
most like badass moments some some very
uh Ant-Man moments that I've been you
know very much waiting for but it felt
like if it was either two movies or if
it was not the third in a series or I
just there was something about how it
landed overall it definitely
it worked for me in the first two acts
more than the third act because there's
a moment and I can't quite piece
together where it was but there's a
moment going into the third act where I
just feel the stake shift in a way that
I was like oh okay this is where this is
going so I had had fun up until that
point and I was engrossed in the world
oh by the way the character designs are
absolutely stunning there's so much
beautiful character work here there's so
much stunning imagery of these insane
new creatures that I think absolutely
deliver I really loved the imagination
in the quantum realm I really loved what
they were able to do by making us uh
believe in imagination there's so many
images that feel like Pure Imagination
Quantified and I and I love that but I
definitely found that by the time we got
to the third act that Glee that
overwhelming sense of wonder turned into
me overthinking the ramifications the
consequences and I don't know if that's
a problem of a giant shared Universe I
don't know if that's a problem of this
having to be contained so you're you
know wondering about their characters I
don't know if that's a problem of you
know we've mapped out five to seven to
ten years we've got a movie in 2025
called the Kang Dynasty I don't know
what that's a symptom of but I'm
definitely aware that I was thinking of
it instead of being engrossed and the
movie made me do that fairly often where
I was never fully in the quantum realm
with them I was watching and and I think
the best superhero movies certainly the
best movies you feel like you're with
these characters and when a superhero
movie can do that where it can have a
reality at an 11 make you feel like
you're running alongside them that is
the dream goal and I definitely felt
slightly removed I felt like I was
looking through the glass of ants I felt
like I was I was on the ant farm with
them in Ant-Man one and two more and I
was outside the ant farm feeding the
ants it's a lot of ant metaphors in this
review I definitely didn't feel as
connected as I wanted to even though I
love the family elements even though I
loved a lot of those things it never
felt like I was with them in a way that
I really wanted to the comedy versus
drama balance is really interesting
because I've heard from a few people
that didn't like the film there wasn't
enough comedy I found the comedy really
refreshing in that I got to laugh and
after phase four there's a lot of not
laughing there's a lot of sadness and
the joy this movie brought was
definitely something I needed I do feel
like we're entering a more joyous era in
Phase five we've mourned we've gone to
therapy we've had a lot of losses this
was more joyous in a really wonderful
way in a way that I really wanted it to
be and I do credit Peyton reads comedy
timing and I do credit obviously Paul
Rudd being Charming Carnet but it wasn't
just that it was the Hank Pam Janet
relationship being drama heavy and US
feeling more in Paul Rudd's head in a
way that you were able to experience the
drama of family but also Paul Rudd
inherently being funny allowed some of
the drama to be comedic so the thing I
think it did best was present characters
that shouldn't work well balance comedy
and drama with insane visuals so I do
feel like This lends itself to the
deeper sci-fi the 70s sci-fi and the
Doctor Who stuff the Star Trek the Star
Wars world the character design
especially is all very much that world
so as far as balancing tone dromedy
comma and the Star Wars Star Trek sci-fi
I do feel like is unique to this film
but it does for me suffer in the third
act because of the world they built
being what it had to be so yeah overall
enjoyed but definitely the most
conflicted I've ever felt walking out of
a Marvel film I definitely have had uh
movies where I've like not for me and
movies that are like that was awesome
this is a more like I don't know how I
feel because I really loved the opening
and then I really found myself in my
head in the entire third act and I'm
excited to see it again to see how that
lands I'm excited to hear what people
think but uh yeah it was an interesting
Journey see it in IMAX because it is
visually stunning prepare yourself for a
Sci-Fi epic in a way that is almost
removing it kind of takes you over here
and I don't know what I would change
there but in the spoiler review I'm
going to tell you guys the little line
tweaks I would change that would solve a
lot of my problems I'll tell you a
couple story beats that change don't
solve a lot of my problems and we're
gonna do a live stream so tune in
Saturday for that but in the meantime
conflicted my review conflicted my
rating score C for conflicted not for a
letter grade because I have to decide
later and my overall thoughts talk to me
in a week okay reject Nation I
appreciate you like subscribe to the
YouTube things I should have said the
top kisses
foreign